jochen sanio propose voyage sans
passeport
plaçant du dard mon front et trempés de
sueur le soleil du matin la poussière
des chemins harcèle le pauvre docteur
c'est le chant la complainte de tous les
porteurs du népal le champ qu'il répète
nos dos courbé sous l'effort leurs
cordes interminable ressemblent pas les
frais mise à feu
c'est vers le teraï pays de la zone
que va avoir lieu une chasse à dos
d'éléphant dès les premiers pas de
l'animal la réalité s'impose celle de
l'ehf en peut pénétrer dans cette jungle
où les herbes large découpe en arrive
parfois à dépasser le niveau des dettes
des chasseurs juchés sur leurs montures
inlassablement pendant des heures ils
vont battre la forêt franchir des
collines et des petites amendes
s'enfoncer dans les sous-bois
inexplicable à la recherche des serres
qui peuplent la région
élégance être l'être sauf le respect
qu'on doit on a vraiment l'impression
qu'ils aimeraient se curer les dents
lorsqu'un sel et abattu il est laissé
sur place des chasseurs rentes et les
éléphants repartent guidée par le sens
de l'orientation extraordinaire leurs
cornacs et ils repartent à seule sa de
récupérer la victime et de la ramener au
camp parfois en pleine nuit sitôt à
terre la domesticité des couples serre
en tranches de bianchi sont mises à
sécher sur une plaie installé au dessus
d'un foyer de braise cette viande ainsi
conserver et ramené dans la vallée où
elle constitue une réserve appréciable
pendant les longs mois de la mousson
mais déjà nous avons quitté les arbres
immenses et la jambe mystérieuse du
terrail pour rejoindre en quelques
heures d'une piste tourmentée et
poussiéreuses le centre du folklore les
palais dans la vallée de katmandou
les moines de backgammon ou j'accueille
tout d'abord avec leurs danses
religieuse
regardez ces costumes de feuilles et
rappelez vous si vous l'avez vu un de
nos récents voyages son passeport aux
commandes il avait exactement le même
genre de costume
cette jeune fille joue sur la sambre à
aider ses amis c'est vivre la danse
danse craché juré est presque le samedi
cette grâce de la danseuse a été
immortalisée depuis des siècles par les
artisans népalais nous la retrouvons
sous le moule des fondeurs de bronze est
également dans la légèreté et la
précision des peintres sur bresle
une famille de quatre manu possède en
effet le privilège de fabrique essais en
vol depuis de nombreuses générations
l'ombre elle est un des symboles
religieux est essentielle
moody's chaque famille possède son
ombrelle plus ou moins 20 ans qui
participe aux cérémonies de tout genre
de la vie quotidienne les us ont inscrit
des motifs religieux des dieux et des
déesses des serpents sacré on a gardé
les peintres surnombre elles sont
considérées comme des artisans sacré les
potiers eux comme des artisans populaire
le potier népalais lance son tour d'une
façon différente d'une autre et je me
vais la pâte avec le même geste précis
que ses semblables
une autre forme d'artisanat utilitaires
les imprimeurs sûr et en avant
l'industrie mécanique du marché des
tissus appelé indienne le népal
possédait un commerce florissant
d'imprimeur sur et hors quelques
familles continuent à en assurer la
tradition les moussa impressions sont
sculptés avec précision à l'aide de
petits burins les images ainsi formé
représentent des figures religieuses ou
des motifs décoratifs semoule et
humecter dans pg talent préparé par les
femmes qui vont chercher sur les flancs
des collines des plantes réservé à cet
usage
l'artisan n'a plus qu'à appliquer son
moule et a répété son geste
tout au long de la pièce des tos cette
forme d'artisanat archaïque se retrouve
dans la fabrication du papier dit
népalais au pied d'une colline hulu
canalisation de bambou amène une eau
fraîche et limpide une famille
d'artisans à préserver
là aussi les vieilles traditions de pays
des écorces de certains arbres des plans
sont mises à macérer dans le vieux
chaudron de cuivre puis portez à
ébullition la pâte ainsi obtenue est
d'écraser sur un pignon actionné par le
poids d'un homme
les impuretés en sont enlevés et une
seconde cuisson rend la pâte homogène
on plonge dans cette pâte de larges
cadre de bois temps d'une fine toile
sécher au soleil une demi-heure après la
feuille de papier se détache et par
surcroît un excellent papier buvard
et voici une forme beaucoup plus récent
de l'artisanat népalais le travail des
bibelots de voix et dévoile ses petits
personnages naïveté délicats ces fines
représentation des pagodes du pays se
vendent facilement aux touristes
toute la famille participe à ce labeur
sculptant avec les mains et semble-t-il
un peu aussi avec les pieds ce commerce
artisanal trouve ses clients dans la
foule disparate des grands hôtels de
katmandou installé comme celui ci dans
d'anciens palais rana voici la tâche en
sanctuaire bouddhiste de batna à l'est
de katmandou où violoneux criard et
craché mais d'une incomparable prestance
nous accueille
c'est à batna pts que réside le fameux
china lama ambassadeur spirituel du
dalaï lama ou n'est pas
tout autour du stup à des centaines de
drapeaux de prière floch tôt vendée
himalaya et c'est justement l'époque de
la fête de la poudre rouge cérémonie
mieux religieuse me populaire qui
consiste à asperger abondamment dans un
geste d'amitié et même de bénédiction
toutes les personnes que l'on ans comme
les gamins du village profite évidemment
de cette journée pour s'en donner à
coeur joie
un épais mur d'enceinte protège le scoop
à proprement dit et porte des niches ou
sont scellés des moulins à prières de
bronze que les fidèles font
inlassablement tournée
l'enceinte franchie ils vont se ranger
respectueusement pour assister à une
cérémonie d'offrande abboud a dirigé par
le china lama en personne
cérémonie en plein vent impressionnante
par le contraste était petit groupe de
moines officier au pied du stupa
majestueux et dans ce paysage grandiose
cérémonie accompagnée sur plus d'un
tamar des tuyaux et des tambours
généreusement actionné par le prince
et la cérémonie s'achève par la
présentation des offrandes composé de
viser des fruits placé dans un grand
plateau du cuivre est présenté au jury
vida avant d'être dispersés à la foule
et ce au son des comptes dans lesquelles
les moines somme
les 28 alliés nous avons conçu un voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec un film de maurice braud
et christian portier montage on est
guéri script jacques nouard sont alain
gautier illustration sonore dominic
palladini réalisation solange péters